what if liberals ever done for us sure
they gave us Liberty metropolitan
intellectuals and soil artists but where
did they come from
and why has the liberal elite become a
term of abuse liberalism is a worldview
based on liberty and equality of
opportunity
liberals value free trade open
competition and freedom of expression in
recent years populist movements have
attacked the liberal cause they prefer
keeping jobs for their own people
shunning immigration and favoring
domestic production over imported goods
protection will lead to great prosperity
and strength populist movements have won
referendums and elections in Britain
America Poland and Hungary while France
and Canada are holdouts for the liberal
course not pathetically mouth neither me
populist think liberals have become too
elite removed from the concerns of
ordinary people and strayed too far from
their founding principles
so what were they back in the 17th
century elites really did rule the world
kings and queens reigned by divine right
the state dictated to religion and
earned your house and land but then
along came to English philosophies
Thomas Hobbes the law is the public
conscience and John Locke the end of law
is not to abolish or restrain but to
preserve an enlarged freedom Hobbes
introduced the idea that people give up
natural rights to freedom in exchange
for security and protection according to
Locke this social contract was rooted in
the duty of all individuals to respect
the rights of others
the Liberals that came after Hobbes and
Locke believed in equal opportunity for
war well all white men they said people
should be allowed to keep the fruits of
their labor and have the freedom to
fulfill their dreams instead of going to
war to gain wealth countries should
embrace trade treaties this new
philosophy would be put into practice
most diligently on the other side of the
Atlantic America was founded on the
principles of equality and individual
liberty it became the world's first
liberal society we hold these truths to
be self-evident that all men are created
equal soon after the French overthrew
their monarchy and replaced it with the
liberal People's Republic but it was the
industrial revolution that galvanized
liberalism as the world's dominant
political theory a seismic shift towards
self-made wealth replaced the inherited
power of the aristocracy liberalism has
underpinned Western democracy ever since
but it evolved during the 20th century
across the world liberalism has made
more room for government involvement
providing education welfare and
regulating the markets but in America
the word has been hijacked liberalism is
now used as an insult to describe
left-wing progressives who support
political correctness and bossy
governments populist argue that today's
liberal elites are just as powerful and
aloof as the old aristocracy
rampant commercialization and
globalization have left many people
behind we've been here before in late
19th century America so-called robber
barons formed vast empires and
accumulated massive wealth politics
became corrupted giving a sense the
society was dividing into winners and
losers but a succession of reformers
like President Theodore Roosevelt took
on these business aristocracy's and
cleaned up government all this helped to
enhance social mobility just as
liberalism reformed itself then it must
reform itself again the rise of populism
is not the death knell for the liberal
project it's a call to action up your
game or else
[Music]
you